ok
[Musica]
è stato un gioco da ragazzi entrare in
casa lavoro guarda adesso
[Musica]
iniziamo
c'è nessuno che ho parlato
[Musica]
no
cipolle
finite le carote
a queste cipolle
piangere
[Musica]
da mangiare veramente è successo
qualcosa di strano che è successo
praticamente stavo tagliando le carote e
si sono trasformate in cipolle come
fanno le però improvvisamente
trasformarsi cipolle da solo un po
strano ma ti ricordi che da ieri sta
succedendo qualcosa di strano in questa
casa a dire che sia collegato a questo
alle cipolle alle carote comunque mi
stavo preparando un po e volevo fare
appunto lett
altri cipolle
com'è possibile non ha senso alle
cipolle
vabbè allora visto che abbiamo tutti
questi cipolle mangiava una bellissima
zuppa di cipolle o al di là
[Musica]
non ci conosciamo ancora ciao io sono il
bombo meglio ne sono il vostro amico
maledetta casa degli umani questo nome
la stoffa si prenderò anche questa
potrebbe seguirlo
[Musica]
dieci anni velluto nero e grigio rosso
dettaglio capello eco tonello questo è
un ottimo lavoro anche il fiocco non è
male non ai livelli delle mie chiaro 6
un'idea tifava riparare un ballo con me
[Musica]
ma che ti ha insegnato a ballare se
fantastica chi già creata avrei potuto
fare un lavoro un po migliore
soprattutto con questi capelli ma è
notevole lo devo ammettere sinti vuoi
far parte della mia collezione è la
collezione del bombolaio del mastro
bambola iol.it bravo di tutti la mia la
collezione più importante che esiste nel
mondo delle bambole
adesso è il momento di finire quello che
ho iniziato la trappola per cui due
umani studi umani che non hanno preso
sul serio il mio lavoro
bene mi sono distratto un po devo
continuare con la mia trappola ci
cascheranno di sicuro bene posso
iniziare
ma mi sembra perfetto
non ti vedrai che concorda
capito questo amore nevada sopra
[Musica]
forse è meglio che vado a controllare ok
ti aspetto qui
[Musica]
cosa succede
ti diverti con me è vitale e che sta
parlando di 66 proprio come le vie
bambole non ti lascerò più andare via
perché è messo tutti questi fili qua per
te è per controllarmi che non
prenderebbe sul serio il mio ordine
quando è l'ordine del pallone
imballaggio io sono il nostro bombolai
febbraio quando del sito esatto il sito
in cui tu hai effettuato l'ordine ai
anche cercato di annullarlo ma sai non
puoi annullare un mio ordine ma la
mettiamo con il diritto di recesso
allora è l'unico fu diritto è quello di
diventare una mia creazione tu e amici
diventerete una mia creazione novero è
possibile a chi vuol dire non sto
capendo niente va bene te lo spiego te
lo spiego io allora vedi di pitti vive
tv dtt ciao io sono vitale devo fare un
regalo ma la mia morte amit una bambola
una bambola averlo fatto una mamma una
personalizzata a scusa tu così fatto
dove si è andato nel marc webb
no no no che cedono ordine cancello
cancello cancello cancello invece mi
dato l'accesso a tutto alla casa le
ciocche di capelli
la lacrima e adesso è adesso
adesso questo diventerete una mia
creazione solo tornerà il mio
laboratorio ma è vero che verrete
trovarmi è vero che venite a trovarmi io
lo so ma non ho capito ma almeno ora
presto dov'è stato
[Musica]
finalmente adesso che ho tutto quello
che mi serve il mio piano finalmente
puoi iniziare posso creare la bambola
perfetta finalmente con la sua ciocca di
capelli sono riuscito ad allenarla è
perfetta
esattamente quanto mese la lacrima
eccoti lacrima finalmente non che sono
una cosa devo cercare di farli venire
qui come posso fare
come posso fare a casa ma certo un'idea
o un idea di fare chi far venire qua li
inviterò a venire qua dicembre il che
l'unico modo per liberarsi di me sono
gelli vanno a genio
tu diario mio resta con me andiamo il
momento
[Applauso]
[Musica]